[Musique]
un an après l'élection de la nouvelle
assemblée les élus du conseil
départemental se sont réunis ce mercredi
22 juin dans l'hémicycle du palais de la
source à l'occasion d'une séance
plénière synonyme de premier point
d'étape de la mandature mais avant cela
la séance a débuté avec l'adoption à
l'unanimité d'une motion de soutien à la
filière canne le prix de la can n'a pas
évolué depuis 2010 est les négociations
sont tendues difficile je suis même
moore pour ma part extrêmement inquiet
sur l'issue c'est pour cette raison que
la collectivité départementale a
souhaité peser de son poids dans ces
échanges et discussions pour demander à
la fois à l'état d'aller un peu plus
loin par rapport aux 14 millions
accordés aux planteurs peut-être adorent
leur réponde favorablement sur l'
enveloppe des 20 millions qu'ils avaient
souhaité et puis ouvrir une autre porte
c'est à dire demander au gouvernement au
président de la république de solliciter
la creuse pour qu'on puisse modifier le
décret qui fixe le prix d'acquisition de
la tonne de bagasse à l'ordre du jour
figurait notamment la présentation du
rapport d'activités de l'année écoulée
la nouvelle assemblée est élu il y a un
an nous avons donc élaboré un plan de
mandature qui aujourd'hui nous en sommes
déjà à évaluer les premières mesures
d'abord nous travaillons en faveur des
publics les plus vulnérables et la
caravane par exemple de l'accès au droit
et à l'information c'est un moyen
d'aller dans les quartiers pour informer
nos concitoyens de tous les dispositifs
nous mettons en place ensuite nous avons
travaillé dans le domaine de la culture
du sport et nous avons mis en place un
plan 5000 licences pour les personnes
les plus modestes qui veulent pratiquer
leur sport favori au niveau de
l'amélioration de l'habitat on le sait
il ya près de vingt mille habitations
insalubres à la réunion eh bien nous
travaillons pour faire en sorte qu'il y
ait une résorption plus rapide de cet
habitat indigne et 4000 maisons 4000
cases seront rénovés grâce au soutien
financier du département autre point au
programme le plan départemental de
transition écologique et solidaire
validé en mars 2021 après avoir fait le
bilan des actions réalisées ou en cours
les élus ont échangé sur les
perspectives sa mise en oeuvre pour les
prochains mois ce mercredi un plan
interne de prévention et de gestion des
déchets est un plan de mobilité ont été
adoptés à l'unanimité par l'assemblée
bien évidemment la situation budgétaire
de la collectivité a elle aussi été
abordée je le contrat mistral 2021 nous
avons globalement une augmentation de
plus de 4 5% du budget par rapport à
2020 et c'est principalement des
dépenses des associations donc des
dépenses qui relève des compétences
directes du département et leurs
recettes augmenter de 8% donc
globalement les indicateurs sont bons la
situation financière et est actuellement
donc satisfaisante concernant le budget
supplémentaire 2022 nous augmentons
d'environ 45 millions le budget
initialement votés principalement sur
les dépenses toujours des associations
d'accompagnement social des familles
d'une manière générale par rapport à
2021 et le budget de 2022 c'est plus de
100 millions d'euros d'augmentations de
budgets de fonctionnement au service des
usagers du département dont des familles
des enfants de la région les élus ont
également voté la nouvelle stratégie à
destination des publics vulnérables
il ya près de 4500 bénéficiaires plus
qui sur une année ce qui montre bien la
performance du dispositif et le nombre
de bénéficiaires du rsa a diminué
sensiblement d'une année sur l'autre ce
qui montre bien que cette incitation
financière pour une réinsertion
socioprofessionnelle porte ses fruits
deuxième point important l'hébergement
des personnes en situation de
vulnérabilité personnes âgées personnes
handicapées enfants en danger il ya un
plan sur cinq ans qui est programmée par
le département la création notamment de
cinq ehpad duo à l'approché de la
création d'une maison d'accueil
idéal donc pour ce qui concerne
l'enfance en danger eh bien nous allons
créer de nouvelles unités de vie
notamment rattaché au foyer de l'enfance
pour héberger ses enfants en danger avec
une mention particulière pour les
fratries bref il y a un véritable plan
avec 2200 places prévues dans les cinq
ans à venir pour ces personnes en
situation de vulnérabilité et 50
millions d'euros qui seront investis par
le département enfin le président
cyrille melchior a tenu à revenir sur le
sort de la compagnie air austral et de
la sematra assurant que le département
prendra toute sa part dans ce dossier
d'actualité
pour